[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Tom is in
New York hi Tom welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thank you so much for
having me on today sure what's
up um so I'm currently a college student
um I just graduated with my
undergraduate degree um and I'm now
working towards an MBA and I'll graduate
here um in about a year from now so this
upcoming December um and I was just
wondering you know if I should continue
to you know rent in this area or move
back home with my parents uh who live in
New
Jersey uh now or when you graduate with
the MBA when I graduate well yeah
because the timing with the leases and
stuff um for the apartment that I'm
currently in I'll have to renew um you
know sometime this spring if I decide to
stay um where's your job gonna
be uh it's going to be either in New
York City or um Jersey City so very very
close commute um from where I'm
currently living how old are you then
why would you
move I'm 22 okay so okay I'm sorry why
would you move the rent here is uh very
expensive uh we'll say I current the
nice thing is I I I spend currently
2,000 a month in rent um but I do live
with my brother who's graduated he's a
full-time job so that's that's the nice
aspect you know I know it's 2000 is very
expensive um what will you be making
sure uh my estimate is about 90 to
95 okay it's pretty
reasonable yeah so but I didn't know if
it was if it's like you know a good
decision to tie up so much of my you
know income into you know rent just for
the sake of not commuting four hours a
day or three hours a day
yes it's part of
life part of growing up it's not living
in Mama's basement you're you're a grown
man with an NBA making 90 grand you
don't need to live in your mother's
basement okay okay and that's just part
of life I mean and I mean in New York
City 2000 isn't bad dude I mean that's
not bad at
all yeah well it's like 4,000 but I SP
the rent with my brother which I know I
had roommates up until I was married
there's nothing wrong with that yeah and
you know but and you have a reasonable
life as far as commute goes and those
kinds of things ultimately you may end
up making the decision that 100,000 or
990,000 is not enough to live in the
city it may or may not be you can decide
that later but as your first step
following your MBA and following getting
your new $90,000 job um I is not to move
back home with your mom no I would not
do that I think that would be a mistake
in a lot of ways but uh I think I think
it's just part of life man and then you
got to start thinking about okay what
point am I going to where am I going to
be living that I end up putting down
roots and buying something but you don't
have to decide that in the next 24
months I mean just get the job enjoy the
ride right now you've done a great job I
like that advice I moved out at 20 and I
needed some problems Dave and those look
like bills cuz I when I lived at home I
would spend every paycheck I made cuz I
didn't have any bills so I was enjoying
life there you go create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life